♪ ♪
>> Laura: MITT ROMNEY IS
CONSIDERING A RUN FOR THE
SENATE, RAISING THE QUESTION,
WOULD HE BE MORE OF AN ALLY OR
AN ADVERSARY OF PRESIDENT TRUMP?
ROMNEY DELIVERED A SCATHING
SPEECH DURING THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, CALLING
THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP A PHONY AND
A FRAUD.
OUR NEXT GUEST KNOWS BOTH MEN
IS BOTH A ROMNEY'S NIECE AND A
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE REPUBLICANS
NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> ALWAYS GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Laura: WHAT'S MAKING THE
DO?
NUMBER ONE QUESTION, MY INSIDE
SCOOP.
>> I DON'T ASK HIM WHAT HE'S
GOING TO DO, SO I CAN COME ON
CHOSEN SAY I HAVE NO IDEA.
I DON'T EVEN ASK MY DAD.
I WILL SAY MY ADVICE TO ANY
REPUBLICAN IS, SPEND YOUR TIME
FOCUSING ON THE DEMOCRATS.
LOOK WHAT THEY DO IF THEY WERE
HOLDING THE REINS OF THIS
COUNTRY WHERE OUR COUNTRY WOULD
BE TODAY.
FOCUS ON THEN, STOP FOCUSING ON
THE REPUBLICANS.
I ALWAYS SAY, IF YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM AND YOUR FAMILY, DON'T
GO ON JERRY SPRINGER.
THIS PRESIDENT IS DOING A GREAT
JOB.
WE SHOULD BE SUPPORTING HIM.
>> Laura: HE DID SEND OUT THIS
TWEET AFTER THE COMMON
CONTROVERSY PURITY SAID THE
PROPERTY OF IS AS
IT IS INCONSISTENT WITH
AMERICA'S HISTORY AND
ANTITHETICAL TO AMERICAN VALUES.
THAT WAS A DIG AT THE PRESIDENT.
>> WE'VE SEEN MANY DIFFERENT
ACCOUNTS COME FROM THIS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS HAD ITS BEEN
TOTALLY MISREPRESENTED.
I TAKE THE PRESIDENT'S WORD AT
THAT.
>> Laura: YOU'RE TAKING THE
PRESIDENTS WERE OVER UNCLE
MITCH?
>> YES, HE WAS IN THE MEETING.
HE IS REPRESENTING HIMSELF AND
HE'S TALKING ABOUT BETTER
HELP MAKE THIS COUNTRY SAFER AND
GREAT AGAIN.
>> Laura: I THINK ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN, HASN'T WORKED OUT
WELL.
BANNON IS GONE.
FLAKE IS ON HIS WAY OUT.
CORKER WAS KIND OF IN AND OUT.
HE'S GONE.
I DON'T SEE THE PLAY HERE.
OH, I'M GOING TO BE A NEVER
TRUMPER.
OKAY?
I GUESS.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE THAT
GETS YOU.
>> Laura: >> WHAT'S GOIG
>> Laura: >> WHAT'S GOIT
>> Laura: >> WHAT'S GOIO
>> Laura: >> WHAT'S GOIG
>> Laura: >> WHAT'S GOIT
>> Laura: >> WHAT'S GOIY
>> Laura: >> WHAT'S GOIU
>> Laura: >> WHAT'S GOI?
A YEAR INTO THE     THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, WE ARE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE BEHIND.
I HOPE DEMOCRATS DON'T HEAR THE
WORD AND START DOING IT AS WELL.
>> Laura: I KNOW YOU ARE UP
WATCHING THE LATE SHOW LAST
NIGHT.
THIS IS WHAT SCHUMER SAID TO
COLBERT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> HE'S NOT A RACIST.
HE IS THE LEAST RACIST PERSON
YOU'D EVER SEE.
I HAVE A CHALLENGE FOR
YOU WANT TO BEGIN, JUST BEGIN
BIGOTED, SUPPORT THE BIPARTISAN
COMPROMISE THAT THREE
REPUBLICANS AND THREE DEMOCRATS
HAVE PUT ON THE FLOOR, EVERYONE
GAVE AND GET THE DREAMERS SAFETY
HERE IN AMERICA.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, THAT'S
JUST THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS
TRUMP'S REDEMPTION.
GIVE EVERYTHING THEY WANT TO THE
GANG OF SIX, AND THEY WILL HAVE
TEENY BABY STEP TOWARDS NOT
BEING A RACIST.
THANKS, CHUCK.
>> I SAY TO HIM, WANTED TO TAKE
SOME ADVICE FROM YOURSELF 20
YEARS AGO WHEN YOU VOTED FOR A
HAD A BORDER ISSUE?
SUPPORT SOME OF THE THINGS OF
THE PRESIDENT IS PUTTING ON THE
TABLE THAT IS PUTTING OUR
COUNTRY SAFER.
>> Laura: WE HAVE ALL THESE
VACANCIES, RETIREMENTS,
REPUBLICANS GETTING WIPED OUT IN
THE HOUSE.
THEY'RE GOING INTO THE FOLD WISH
LIST HERE.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE TOAST.
WHAT'S THE REAL SCOOP?
>> THE RNC RAISED RECORD MONEY.
WE KNOW THAT THE MIDTERMS ARE
USUALLY BRUTAL.
WE'VE BEEN READY FOR.
WE HAD THE BEST THE DATA AND
GROUND GAME.
WE ARE READY TO COMPETE.
WE HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT'S DOING
WELL.
WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS TO RUN
ON.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT THE
LEADING THE WAY.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL BE WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS HOPED, BUT I WANT
OUR BASED ENERGIZER, SO GO AHEAD
AND WORRY AND GET OUT THERE.
WE HAVE A NATIONAL DAY OF
TRAINING ON SATURDAY ON THE
FIRST ANNIVERSARY -- GET OUT.
ELECTION.
WE WILL HAVE TO WORK AS HARD AS
WE CAN.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW I ALWAYS
ASK YOU THIS, I WANT THE
COMMENTS MOST FREQUENTLY MADE ON
THE RETURN ENVELOPES WHEN YOU
ASK FOR MONEY.
WHAT DO PEOPLE DO?
>> I GOT MY HOMEWORK DONE TODAY
DOLLAR FUND RUN FUND-RAISING IN
JANUARY FOR THE NUMBER ONE THING
THAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING ON THE
PHONES AND ON THE MAIL, WE NEEDT
PHONES AND ON THE MAIL, WE NEEDO
KEEP OUR MAJORITY IN CONGRESS
BECAUSE WE NEED TO SUPPORT THIS
PRESIDENT.
IT'S NOT EVEN US SOLICITING
DONATIONS.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE CALLING
OTHER ELECTION YEAR AND SMALL
DOLLAR DONATIONS.
>> Laura: THEY WANT THE WALL
BUILT.